hey leute wir sind mit dem auto für eine
woche nach österreich gefahren und wir
sind sehr sehr lange gefahren am ersten
tag haben wir dann alpakas gesehen die
haben wir dann angelockt und gefüttert
und naja eigentlich haben wir eins
gefüttert die anderen dachten sich mehr
so gut bin ich aber ich muss schon sagen
alpakas sind sehr sehr sehr lustige
tiere im zweiten tag am ende kutschfahrt
gemacht über vereiste wege durch
zugeschneite wälder und am ende machen
wir dann an einem richtig geilen sehe
ich erst mal gefilmt habe ich hab's elf
ausgemacht und noch mehr service dann
sind wir auch mit einem lift ein berg
hochgefahren weil wir ski fahren wollten
an waren wir allerdings auf dem berg und
hatten aber irgendwie doch keine lust
auf skifahren und haben dann einfach nur
glühwein getrunken aber ich muss
wirklich sagen da oben was sehr sehr
schön es waren halt aber auch nur minus
13 grad und wir mussten dann zu fuß
zurück laufen er war noch allgemein
extrem viel schwimmen extrem viel
schwimmen mega viel ultra viel
eigentlich war mir die restliche zeit
quasi nur schwimmen noch sieben tagen
sind wir nach hause gefahren und das war
wieder eine sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr
sehr sehr lange fahrzeit für den
allerdings wieder zu hause waren lag ihr
gerade mal so viel schnee dass man
darauf ein bisschen driften konnte
automatischer
und das war's dann auch schon von meinem
urlaub sowie lok aus österreich der mich
extrem viel arbeit extrem viel
videoaufnahmen extrem viel speicher und
alles mögliche gekostet hat aber es hat
mir natürlich auch spaß macht und mich
das ganze natürlich nicht machen und ich
würde einfach sagen wenn ihr da auch
radar love love love in jeder spaß dran
hat würde ich mich auf jeden fall über
eine bewertung freuen und dann sehen uns
in einem nächsten video wieder t